[Music]
milkis because you got a milk this this
doesn't look like it's gonna be good
it's a little milky it's like nope
banana like Oh new feeling of soda
beverage that is a new feeling and it's
a good one so this looks like some kind
of ball it looks like a cheese the egg
it looks like a cheesy like eight
regular ingredient and then it starts
getting crazy
peanuts wheat squid sneaky sneaky sneaky
sneaky is weird the fish it's a little
surprising to play that back once though
that crunch these are really good
this sausage may contain tiny black
pieces these are fragments of fish skin
it's like I know you'll panic when you
see tiny black pieces in this sausage
calm down I don't know why but I'm
surprised by how this would look come on
it was like I want it to move and be
shaped and have the consistency of
string cheese but could we make it penis
colored like white person penis color it
just tastes like the beach smell I'm
like a bad day just even though this is
edible as you
the Korean store hahaha my mind is
telling me not to like these when my
body is telling me yes yeah okay do it
what why is that in the inside oh is
that peanut butter
I will eat anything that shape like an
animal it's got red bean and vanilla ice
I love this I want I want my life will
not be complete unless I can have this
regularly I mean it's great it's just
it's just an Ice Cream Sandwich shaped
like a fish which why wouldn't you want
that
[Music]